[Musique]
je ne savais pas
ce qu'était le développement personnel
d'ailleurs je n'en avais jamais entendu
parler
jusqu'à ce jeudi de 2017 où je suis allé
à l'encontre d'un ami
en effet afin de notre conversation
alors que je m'apprêtais à prendre congé
de lui un livre
loyers sur une pile de documents posé
sur son bureau
attira mon attention
la magie du voit grand et est le titre
intéressant me disch je suis curieux de
découvrir quelle est cette magie alors
je lui emprunte et le livre de semaine
mais au bout de quatre jours j'avais
terminé la lecture tellement c'était
intéressant je découvre qu'il existe une
science qui traite du succès une science
qui nous donnent des outils des
techniques et des méthodes pour réaliser
nos rêves mais pourquoi cela ne nous est
il pas enseignée à l'école pourquoi ce
n'est qu'aujourd'hui que je découvre
cela tels sont les quelques questions
qui affluaient dans mon esprit sans
réponse mais bon
à partir de ce moment on ment c'est pour
moi une aventure qui allait me porté ali
des centaines de livres qui traitent du
sujet parmi lesquels 1
dans les circonstances de la rédaction
allait une fois de plus retenir mon
attention
en effet dès l'entamé de ce livre
intitulé les lois du succès l'auteur
napoléon il à cause de cas 1908 il
appelle à rencontrer d'andrew carnegie
l'un des plus riches industriels
américaine de cette époque ce dernier
lui a confié une mission
celle
de se rapprocher de toutes les personnes
qui ont réalisé leur rêve afin de
s'enquérir du secret qui les ont
conduits à ce succès
bien évidemment il a conduit la mission
jusqu'à la fin et le résultat il a
consigné dans ce livre que nous venons
d'évoquer
comme je sais bien le faire je me suis
encore poser des questions
cette étude menée par napoléon il aux
états unis
intégrés tels des africains qui ont
réalisé leur rêve
les conditions d'un succès aux états
unis sont elles les mêmes en afrique et
enfin que fait pour donner aux africains
évoluent à un contexte africain et à que
légaliser le rêve des stratégies
gagnantes qui vont me permettre de paris
ni à la fin
j'ai résolu donc de fait la même mission
que fit napoléon il à son époque à la
seule différence que j'allais cette fois
ci me limiter à un public africain en
général dumas les particuliers un public
camerounais au cameroun et qui ont
réalisé le rêve de
joseph k d'idées fausses haut en passant
par roger milla françoise 1er pascal
monkam et paul fokam
trois camerounais ont eu le mérite est
d'être la pierre angulaire sur laquelle
j'allais bâti cette philosophie du
succès adapté aux africains évoluant un
contexte africain
oui
oui c'est comme rouler en fait ont été
choisis parce que ils ont défié tous les
pronostics qui annonçait que la vie
allait être un échec
le premier ou le connaissez c'est
francine dan
ce jeune gazonné a bâti un village du
cameroun qui dès l'âge de 9 ans était
obligé de travailler dans les mines de
sables ou avoir de quoi manger car sa
famille croupissent dans la misère
il a eu rêve de l'âge de 15 ans lui
devenir champion du monde d'un sport de
combat et aujourd'hui il est deux fois
champion du monde des arts martiaux
mixtes
le deuxième
c'est ce petit gars ceux-là qui les lacs
du neuf en devient orphelin du pet du
sud un accident de la route tout ce
qu'il a comme héritage c'est ça
provenait sans emploi qui a reçu la
compassion d'un des frais de son défunt
mari qui lui a donné une chambre de
quelques mètres carrés me bédard tout
petit lit qu'elle occupait avec son fils
elle dormait sous le lit pendant que le
petit garçon dans mes pâtés ce petit
gars sont là il a eu ma l'a dit que non
je dois sentiments mais de cette
situation humiliante
j'ai un rêve devenir footballeur
professionnel
alors je vais tout donner pour le
réaliser et quelques années après
rigobert song bahanack est devenu une
figure de référence en ce qui concerne
la défense dans le football africain
et le troisième personnage qui n'est pas
très connu d'ailleurs coûtant il a
réalisé un exploit faux ce petit garçon
qui à l'âge de 12 ans a découvert la
première fois l'existence de la
télévision à travers un film la fureur
du tango du style tellement des
passionnés qui l'a dit je vais devenir
comme bruce lee je serai maître de kung
fu oui c'est un camerounais dominique
marsac lang qui a été le premier noir à
être consacré aux moines du temple de
shaolin
sans se connaître sans même s'être
côtoyés à l'avancé trois camerounais ont
mis en application cette stratégie
gagnante qui les ont portés à réaliser
leurs rêves c'est ce que on va voir tout
de suite
la première stratégie c'est d'avoir un
rêve
le rêve ici n'est pas ce que vous voyez
comme il faut bien s'alourdir du fait du
sommeil ne s'est pas de ça qu'il s'agit
le rêve c'est cette projection mentale
pro volontaire que vous faites de vos
meubles dans un futur proche ou lointain
pour vous décider de qui vous êtes de
ceux que vous faites et de ce que vous
avez constamment ce que pourrait penser
le pauvre et son enfant le reste n'est
pas l'apanage des riches lui ré est un
devoir le rêve et la portée du tout être
humain
dans son livre man search pour mini
michael pollak raconte que pendant la
période nazie des juifs était arrêté et
gardé prisonnier dans des camps de
concentration dont le plus célèbre est
celui d'un switch chaque jour des
personnes mourraient dans les prisons ou
encore
auchan des travaux forcés mais de ceux
qui ont survécu
michael pollak apple rosstat tous
avaient un rêve qu'il souhaitait
réaliser avant de mourir c'est ce rêve
il leur a permis de tenir bon pendant
que les autres murs un suprenant n'est
ce pas
et vous
quel est votre rêve
la deuxième stratégie gagnante
c'est d'avoir ma de votre situation
actuelle et prendre la décision d'agir à
ce propos je me souviens il ya de cela
cinq hommes j'appelle à un rôdeur
professionnels d'entreprises il se
plaignait le salaire que je reçois est
insuffisante aussi bien le besoin est et
voilà
répondre à toutes mes exigences de
famille et lui a conseillé mais assez
simple trouver un autre emploi plus
valorisant de salé en termes
d'opportunités de progression de
carrière après quelques tentatives
infructueuses il se décourager et
aujourd'hui
cinq ans après à l'heure où je vous
parle il est toujours dans la même
entreprise il occupe le même poste il
pèse pas le même salaire
tout simplement dit qu'il n'a pas eu ma
de sa situation actuelle avoir ma
signifie que nous disons stop ça suffit
ça ne peut plus continuer comme ça là où
les choses changent
ou les choses changent il n'ya pas une
autre option
rigobert song bahanack des lâches tu ne
vas pas eu marre de voir sa mère souffre
il a dit je dois tout faire pour
réaliser mourad bounif valeurs gagnait
l'agencé soit tu m'amènes la souffrance
et cela l'a amené à une folie sans
jamais être à l'ouest du cameroun
après deux sorties l'écho du foot doit
dépasser les il a pris la route pour
aller là où tu vas voir les opportunités
pour devenir un footballeur
professionnel dans un groupe de foudre
et celle là qui nous a promis opportune
d'éclat pour pousser son premier club
red star devant où
l'attendait une stratégie gagnante
choisi un modèle et un anti modèle le
modèle est cette personne là qui a déjà
réalisé ce que vous voulez réaliser qui
a déjà fait ce qu'on voulait faire il
vous montre le chemin vous n'aurez plus
qu'à suivre quelques jours plus facile
de suivre un chemin déjà tracé plutôt
que de réinventer la roue mais dans un
cas comme dans l'autre c'est toujours
possible mais moi je préfère
un chemin déjà tracé
l'anti modèle ici de cette personne qui
est le contraire de ce que vous devez
faire qu'à vous ce que de compromettre
la réalisation de votre rêve francis
nous raconte que son père était ceinture
noire de karaté mais il tombait était
tout sauf si qu'il voulait être pourquoi
parce que son père avait la réputation
de se battre dans les rues de battre sur
sa femme s'ils nous disaient non je ne
vais pas devenir comme lui je veux
devenir un champion qui se bat sur ay
gagner sa vie
aphatie aux stratégies gagnantes
cd quitté l'entraînement neutre ou
hostiles ou l'environnement propice
imaginez vous un beau jour vous vous
rendez à la piscine pour vous immunité
et puis à votre arrivée vous trouvez un
monsieur tout joyeux a6l à pêche à la
main armée sont dans l'eau et vous dites
ou bien commun je suis là j'attends de
pêcher quelques poissons avant de
marteler chez moi il a perdu la tête
n'est ce pas il pourrait rester toute
une décennie sans jamais apercevoir
l'ombre du moindre passe au tout
simplement pas traîné pendant
environnement adéquat pour atteindre cet
objectif
l'environnement également peut être
décliné en trois dimensions la première
plein déroulement géographique la vigne
le pays le quartier dans lequel vous
évoluez est ce que l'environnement et où
vous êtes est propice pour y aller vous
de votre rêve parce que le quartier où
vous êtes est ce que le pays où vous
êtes européenne est de réaliser votre
rêve si ce n'est pas le cas à l'autre en
sommet le si vous ne pouvez pas le
transformer alors quitté le
la deuxième dimension de l'environnement
c'est l'environnement organisationnel
les associations les entreprises dans
lesquelles vous évoluez est ce que votre
entreprise est propice pour réaliser
votre rêve est ce que votre association
est un plus long permet de réaliser
votre la réponse est non alors
transformé là si on ne veut pas alors
qu'ils étaient là et aller là où c'est
mieux et enfin la dernière dimanche à
l'entraînement c'est l'environnement et
national les personnes que vous côtoyez
au quotidien sont-elles propice pour
réaliser votre rêve ou alors essentielle
plutôt des poisons qui vont être de
mauvaise de novatek pour vous décourager
qui vont vous empoisonner le rêve ou
même comme j'aime bien le dit qu'ils
vont manger votre rêve
si ces personnes sont des mangeuses
dirais-je alors n'essayez pas de les
transformer parler de moins en moins de
votre rêve avec elle
il cherchait des personnes qui ont la
même vision que vous les mêmes amis
ciotat et vous donneront probablement
des idées qui vont vous aider à vous
réalisez
la cinquième stratégie gagnante s'est
fait confiance à la loi de l'attraction
on doit appeler la présidence par les
uns la providence divine par les autres
et le hasard par les autres encore la
loi de l'attraction est ce phénomène là
qui fait survenu dans votre vie tout ce
support vous concentrez vos pensées vos
émotions et vos actions au quotidien
vous vous êtes probablement déjà arrivé
un jour de vous donner à fond soit un
objectif de tout fait de vous donner à
plus de 500 pour ça mais jusque là
président qui joue pas atteint et puis
un beau jour alors que vous n'y pensez
même plus compte la magie vous voyez un
concours de circonstances se mettre en
place vous portez à la tête de votre
objectif oui cela lois de l'attraction
en actions perdu confiance
et comme le dit si bien l'écrivain paulo
coelho dans son livre l'alchimiste
quand vous désirez quelque chose tout
l'univers au spi à ce que vous l'obtenez
la 6ème stratégie gagnante
c'est de trouver la motivation dans le
pourquoi
imaginez vous un beau jour c'est pendant
les vacances vous voulez un peu changé
vous avez été trop stressé pendant
l'année prenez votre voiture vous prenez
la route et plus voilà vous démarrez un
moment donné vous vous rendez compte que
le cas durant vient déjà marqué dans le
réservoir vous continuez quand même et
après la voiture s'arrête net plus
possibilité plus de possibilités
d'avancer que ce que vous avez à faire
c'est de trouver la station service la
plus proche afin de vous approvisionner
en carburant l'a fait image la voiture
c'est vous la route c'est le trajet que
vous aurez à mener pour atteindre votre
rêve le carburant qui vient à manquer
c'est votre motivation et la station
service et le pourquoi de la réalisation
de votre rêve
réalisez vos turenne ne sera pas de tout
repos malheureusement je voudrais bien
vous dire le contraire mais je préfère
être honnête avec vous
alors il vous arrivera parfois de
manquer de motivation mais durant ces
moments souvenez vous vous devez aller à
la station service près le plein de
votre réservoir dont demandez vous
pourquoi est ce que je me suis engagé à
la réalisation de ce rêve qu'est ce que
ça va me procurer la réponse vous
donnera un regain d'énergie et de
motivation dominion matin certaines
racontent que tu as été admis au temple
de shaolin il pouvait passer trois jours
sans se laver sans se baigner pas parce
que vraiment ce que double non parce
qu'il était exténué par les
entraînements ne vais même pas la force
de me frotter son corps est dit qu'un
jour et s'est demandé mais qu'est ce que
je fous ici pourquoi je me suis toutes
ces souffrances j'avais mon entreprise
d'expertisé comptable pour rapporter de
l'argent
pourquoi j'ai laissé cela pouvait ni
dans ceux trop où je conduis tout cela
alors il dit j'ai regardé la montagne et
je me suis dit je ne peux pas avoir
quitté l'afrique pouvait ni t'amuser ici
si tu es là c'est parce que tu aimes le
kung fu et tu va tout donner vous devez
ni maître de kung fu
et vous
quel le pourquoi
la possible de votre rêve enfin la
dernière stratégie gagnante
c'est de travailler du et d'être
déterminé
si c'était facile assurez-vous nous
serons tous milliardaires dans cette
salle si c'était facile nous serons tous
champions du monde dans ma soeur me
françois serrano si c'était facile nous
serons tous deux milliards deux compères
cas de défaut sont maintenant c'est
parce que c'est pas facile que tout le
monde n'y arrive pas alors vous devez
fait preuve d'endurance et de
détermination
la détermination est pour la réalisation
de votre rêve c'est que le sabre est
entre les mains de samouraï
lors du têt 2013 la psychologue 1/2 la
lie des crêtes
à partager une idée du moins le résultat
d'une richesse qu'est l'âme unis s est
demandé
qu'est ce qui fait que dans la vie c'est
injuste personnes réussissent et
d'autres ne réussissent pas
elle allait donc mais les enquêtes dans
les écoles auprès d'un centre
d'instruction était également au près et
c'est un candide en or ou d'autographes
aux etats unis elle s'est rendu compte
que ce n'est pas l'intelligence qui
déterminent le succès ce n'est pas le
quotient intellectuel qu'il est ému le
succès mais c'est notre capacité à être
ici c'est notre détermination
à assurer sans détermination votre grave
ne va rester que de l'imagination on
pourra même pas la pêche oui je sais
mais ça n'est pas mais vous y en a qui
avait levé la main lui j'ai une question
je peux vous rassurer que vos rêves
deviennent réalité alors mesdames et
messieurs allez est rien les et vos
rêves je voulais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]